and the allegations differ a lot in terms of severity. For the
sake of not poisoning the well, I'm going to bring up a few points
in her eight-page document that are just completely unsubstantiated
or outright false. She claims Cameron is a but never levies any
allegations or stories about a forced assault, as well as claiming
Cameron sleeps while listening to ASMR of women screaming. Both
of these claims are pretty extreme and again to be fair to Cameron,
they lack any credibility. the rest of >> one time I came
through his room on one of these nights and he was straight up
listening to guttural screams of women while he was sleeping.
This is maybe the funniest allegation I've ever seen in my entire
life. It is one of those things where I'm like dude this is so
absurd that I have a hard time not just like laughing and like
just giggling at dude that's insane. I don't want to say gig.
I don't want to do that. But like most >> of her document,
minus a few nitpicks, mostly towards the end, seems to line up
roughly with what Cameron himself admits to. She even provides
recordings to back up a good chunk of what she claims, which
is what I'll be focusing on. >> How old is Cameron? I think
Cameron was 18 or 19 in this case. I think he was just an adult.
>> One of the first claims made by Krexa is that Cameron
had choked her on a live stream, saying this was not a planned
or consented to encounter. Krexa is seen initially going along
with the joke, but when Cameron takes things too far, she pushes
him away and is visibly distressed. I'm stealing your stream
for a minute. >> We've watched this.
>> I'm going to destroy you here.
>> What the >> What was Cameron's response to this?
>> just weird. Just just weird stuff. >> He lies.
He takes the clip out of context, refuses to show the full video,
and acts as if Crexa is crazy for ever being uncomfortable with
something like >> Everything between me and her was pretty
fine up until this point. I'd asked her to keep the stream entertained
for a while cuz I had to use the restroom. And when I came back,
we were posing a bit in front of the camera. I thought it'd be
a funny time to pretend to kill her since that was the joke we
>> Wow, what a funny time. >> On the game about the
killer, a joke she was already playing along with. And you can
see that in her face. She was >> I think so. Can y'all
hear me?
I'm stealing the stream for a minute. >> I'm going to just
stroll it here. She was initially laughing and then she tugged
away. I assumed it was because I >> Oh, hold on. Do we
see it? She was
>> Oh, did we see it? Did we Is that the same clip, guys?
>> I'm going to destroy it here. She was >> Is is
that the clip that he's showing? Is that the full clip? >> Laughing
and then she tugged away. I assumed it was because I was kind
of pushing her around a bit when I was doing that. When I said,
"I'm going to destroy you." Uh, stream moved on and everything
was fine. >> No, that wasn't a cut I made. That is Cameron's
video in full without any modification. Remember, the full clip
shows the initial arm around the neck, which Kraxa plays along
with, and then the hand around the throat, which is clearly what
she takes issue with. What is Cameron's excuse for cutting this
out and effectively smearing and crazy painting Craigslist? Well,
wait, why did he even talk about it with somebody? He t that's
on the record >> in a video he posted a month later titled
the r/ Oana degenerates. He addresses why he cut this clip. So,
>> no. Why would you self snitch, dude? Somebody get this
guy in touch with Bruce Rivers. point I want to fully take on
the chin is me cutting the ending of the clip of me and Craigslist
streaming together. Now, the intention of me showing that in
the first place was to show the timestamps and what was going
on beforehand to show the inconsistencies and hypocrisies within
Craigslist story based on what happens later on in that same
stream with the timestamp visible as well as my side of the story
from my perspective and my point of view. In the original edit,
there was no cut off. However, a friend of mine suggested that
for two reasons it should be cut off. Number one, for time sake,
cuz the video was getting really long. >> I needed, guys,
I needed to get that second and a half back. Okay, that one and
a half seconds was critical. It definitely wasn't, you know,
primarily anything else. It was mostly saving >> Regardless,
in the video after, I still own that what I did there was dumb
and it was a breach of personal space and boundaries and it was
wrong of me and I still feel bad about it. >> this makes
absolutely no sense. Cameron's response is almost 3 hours long
and the full clip would have added what 3 seconds to the video.
Cameron also refuses to show the full clip of him choking Krexa
in this video. So, it goes without saying this is just more blatant
dishonesty and obfuscation on Cameron's part. Krexa claimed that
she had confronted Cameron once the stream was over and explained
how he had made her feel uncomfortable. Cameron responds by telling
her it was a joke and that she's overreacting and to go sleep
on the couch. Eventually, Cameron goes into the living room to
chastise Krexa for not forgiving him. She begins recording this
encounter, which I'll let speak for itself for the most part.
>> My last chance. What the does that mean? >> I
don't want to be threatened to be listened. What the No, >> just
relax. >> Just leave me alone. >> Respond to me.
Don't respond. >> What the [__] >> Respond
to me. Just relax.
I apologize for you. I apologize. Okay, >> you now
I just
>> I'm extremely anxious now. >> Excuse me. >> I
want you to leave me alone.
>> Please just leave me alone
>> right now.
>> You don't control me.
>> Let I get the right to my own space. >> You do.
Absolutely. Please just leave >> Listen, I'm listening
to this now for the first time. Okay,
>> Cameron refuses to >> seems pretty easy to walk
away. Like I >> leave her alone despite Craig trying to
draw a clear boundary and Cameron eventually snaps and explains
that she can't control him and this is his house and he can be
where he wants to. Now, to be clear, I'm not going to act like
this is insane. This is pretty light all things considered. Cameron
obviously shouldn't be power tripping on his friend who is obviously
distressed. And regardless if Krexa was indeed overreacting or
not, this is at the very least escalatory and unnecessary behavior
on Cameron's part. Around the same time, Cameron decides to vague
post on a Snapchat story about Krexa and their fight that they
had. In the morning, upon seeing this, Krexa accuses Cameron
of smear campaigning her on Snapchat. Cameron initially denies
this, but when KXA says she had screenshotted the post, he immediately
folds. So,
>> this apology is
good and correct, but if you really mean it, why are you smear
campaigning on your Snapchat right now? >> I'm not. >> Do
you so much and always find a way to feel stabbed? Can't even
apologize because it's never good enough. Treat me like instead.
Just hurts when you meant no harm. Never made the mistake before
and didn't see it as nothing when you try to give them everything
you can. I don't know why this would be good to make public.
Insecure douchebag.
Eight out. Okay. Well, well, you know, >> that's some insight.
>> I What do you mean? >> I saw your story this morning.
So, you talked about me treating you like, and you can play dumb
about it, but I took a picture of it just in case.
>> My private story. >> So, if you really mean all
this. >> Yeah, that was pretty emotional. that that was
created 10 hours ago right after everything happened. >> Crex
says she doesn't want to be smear campaigned and Cameron responds
by saying she isn't and that she's the only one who had seen
the story. >> I don't want to be smear campaigned.
>> You're the only one who's seen it so >> We can
see via the provided screenshot that the posts are 8 hours old.
So, the likelihood of her being the only person who has seen
them is pretty low.
It depends on like
this guy seems like a weird enough person that he would make
these stories and then set the visibility to just her, right?
>> Call this a smear campaign is a bit silly. These posts
just seem kind of like sympathy bait targeted at friends or followers,
if that. However, this doesn't really change the fact that Cameron
was lying to Craigslist's face about posting about her. As silly
and as trivial as this might seem, this is yet another example
of Cameron's dishonest behavior. And this happens a lot throughout
Cameron's response to Craigslist's allegations. even at one point
decides to leak one-sided messages where he only shows Krax's
side. He does this in response to being accused of having a fetish
by Krexa in an unreleased interview. She had a kink, a very very
very strong kink involving the lack of consent.
>> But then externally from his
I don't know if he if he knew that. >> Oh, is this Doomer?
No, this is morale made this video >> cuz I didn't really
let him know. So, I can't really sit here and call him a even
though he he does have a fetish, but I >> All right. So,
all right. I won't be holding any punches. That that BDSM fetish
that she mentioned in her document was a fetish that I was not
into and she knew that I was not into. Uh and now she's trying
to push that on me. She's trying to turn the tables even though
all the evidence points to it being her. I don't have that fetish.
She has that fetish.
Uh, and now she's trying to say that I have it.
>> I mean, he is the one who's doing the the public like
hand around the throat. I'm going to destroy her. I don't know,
>> Never published. So, now that that's out of the way,
uh, I won't be pulling any punches. She had a fetish that I was
>> You You can't really tell from these messages, by the
way. Like, the messages he posted, you you literally can't tell
because obviously if you're in a relationship with somebody,
if you're like, "Oh, I'm into this thing." they might play into
that to like make you happy, right?
So, so I wouldn't say her even if she were playing into it messages,
it wouldn't really mean anything to see one-sided messages like
that unless you see messages from him saying, "I'm not into this
or I don't feel comfortable with like this thing. I don't I don't
really trust any one-sided >> not into and that I did not
consent to >> This is an insane overreaction and completely
unwarranted. This serves only to shame and humiliate Krexa, which
ironically enough Krexa predicts in her document. This is all
made even worse when you remember that these aren't false allegations.
While exaggerated at times, these claims that Krexa was making
were based entirely in reality. It seems like he made two entirely
different responses to Krexa and just put them together in his
video back to back. For example, at around the 40-minute mark,
Cameron addresses the claim that he had spread AI or revenge
of Krexa. So, here she lies and claims that I was sending revenge
of her. Prove it to me. She's claiming I sent revenge. Prove
it to me. That never happened. To be clear, his response here
is perfectly fine. It's obviously on Craigslist to provide evidence,
especially for a claim like this. However, >> we're looking
for him to be >> an hour later in his video. He addresses
the same exact allegation, but this time he tries to guess which
video she is talking about and decides to play it for his audience.
She claimed at one >> point that I was sharing an AI of
her and a bunch of other really weird claims that had zero bases
>> like I don't know if he like got an act I was like you
told me about this one time and then I was thinking about it
like uh maybe it's an actress maybe it's an AI >> context
Ally had apparently claimed that someone had seen a video of
Krexa being forcibly towards me I did at one point after being
asked show Ann a screenshot of the following clip since she wanted
to see if I was being honest about Krexa Ali MCC's unreleased
interview with Krexa Why? I don't know. I'm guessing it just
doesn't even exist. But you said somebody has seen this this
video. >> Go ahead, post it. If it's real, as you say,
let me see it. >> Yeah, honestly, I I would like You know
what? You're right. I want to see this [__] video.
>> Y'all notice the stuttering there is cuz she knows what
it is. It's this right on screen. And the reason she knows is
because she thought she made me delete it and tried calling this
revenge. This isn't There is no nothing there. The entire video
I'm not going to share it cuz I'm embar. >> Okay. I want
full context on whatever this is cuz if something's censored,
it looks like remotely. It's very weird. It feels very weird,
right? If it's remotely, I want to know. I want full contact,
but it's there's no in it. But she tried calling this revenge
and wanted me to delete it. Now I know why. And I'm glad I didn't.
Here you go. Uh but yeah, she tried to get me to delete this.
I told her I did so she'd leave me alone. It's insane that Cameron
admits to refusing to delete this intimate video and decides
to show it publicly on YouTube. As far as I can tell though,
there isn't >> Hold on. Intimate video. I want I think
M should say exactly what it is. >> Relating this video,
which is just kissing, to anything revenge related. But regardless,
stuff like >> just kissing. >> This happens constantly
throughout Cameron's response. He basically responds to every
>> Well, he said it's just kissing, right? >> As
I can tell though, there isn't anything relating this video,
which is just kissing, to anything revenge related. But regardless,
>> he's just kissing. Okay. So, if it's just him, >> it's
kind of weird to have >> constantly throughout Cameron's
response. He basically responds to everything twice and gives
different answers each time, which again is just really odd,
and I'm not sure why he did this. Probably the worst case of
Cameron outright smearing Crexa happens around the time she was
kicked out of his apartment. An incident that involved Cameron
calling the police on her. Long story told short, they got into
an argument. Crexer runs outside. Cameron, after calling the
crisis hotline, follows her. At some point, Crexa runs back inside
to take refuge with Cameron's roommate. Eventually, the police
show up and investigate the situation. Let's see how Cameron
initially explains this situation. >> Bro, these these
people are like speed running some right here. >> She refused
to listen, bolted out of my house after hopping over the couch,
and was clearly going into some mental breakdown. So, I immediately
called a mental health hotline to get advice. I They told me
to locate her immediately. I first grabbed my keys just in case
she tried locking me out. and they told me to find her because
she could hurt herself. And as it turns out, according to the
police report, she was wielding a knife. This is when I decided
to take some time to call for a Baker Act, which is when someone
going through a mental health crisis gets immediate help and
treatment. I actually have a copy of the report. Some details
will be censored for safety reasons and as to not dox
>> Man, I need
Man, this is a one-sided. This feels
fault. Uh, but according to her describing the situation, >> in
fact, I would want to see the roommate. What does a roommate
have to say, too? Let me look at these uh these screenshots from
this. It's all good, bro. She's calming down. I'm so sorry. No
problem. >> Hell, we all go through. I'm for real confused
and concerned. Females are emotionally people, bro. Are emotionally
people.
They're actually I I would I know this is like cringe, but I
would say they're probably people in most ways. Sometimes you
just have to let them go through the motions. They will come
back around once they calm down. Time to call for a Baker Act,
which is when someone going through a mental health crisis for
safety reasons.
>> So, comp
Luna, white hoodie, black shorts, known to have a 6-year-old
pocket knife. Okay. Shown violent tendencies via social media
toward a select group of people acted on this date at blank for
29A threats >> and as to not do her or any locations involved.
Uh, but according to her background track, she had a history
of violent threats online and was Baker acted in 2016. These
were things I wasn't entirely aware of other than the Baker Act,
but I didn't know what it was for or when it was. >> These
are homicidal threats, by the way. They're not These appear to
not be threats. These are homicidal threats. She got a knife
and she's making homicidal threats. >> Video Cameron presents
a police report that allegedly claims Krex was Baker acted in
2016 for violent behavior. But if you've been following this
video so far, you already know that Cameron has a well-established
history of dishonesty and evidence tampering. So, let's actually
examine the report he provided. The redactions on this report
are sloppy, uneven in height, poorly aligned, and in some cases,
even overlapping the documents layout borders. It immediately
raises a question. Did Cameron censor this report himself? And
if so, what exactly is he trying to hide? Well, we don't have
to speculate. Cameron was directly asked about this on a recent
live stream. >> There's hype. I'm not going to get it day
one. Why did you fabricate your report to the authorities
and then hide all the replies
on your newest tweets? >> Okay, first of all,
uh I didn't. That's a lie. I didn't fabricate my freedom of information
report
with redacted information that I couldn't see. I don't know how
anybody else got unredacted information.
So, I just got it from the Freedom of Information Act. I had
replies because these people are bad faith, malicious actors
like yourself. So, you can go. Thank you. >> No wonder
we haven't heard from Ralph for a while until recently. No, Mal
was talking about doing this. He I we all knew what his project
was. That was going to be this. >> First off, Cameron didn't
get the report from the Freedom of Information Act. He got it
from FPS Diesel who provided him the uncensored copy. He shows
this himself in his response video, but if you want definitive
proof, here's FPS Diesel sending me an unedited screen recording
of him scrolling through Cameron's DMs, opening the file he sent
Cameron, and it is completely uncensored. If you want even more
definitive evidence, you need to look further than the affforementioned
video titled The R/ Osana Degenerates uploaded a month. >> Why
does this guy just lie about everything? I don't know what. Just
don't comment. No comment. Like, I'm not responding to anything
about that. How hard is that? >> After his response video,
>> it's well edited. Morau is a fantastic editor. Like
unironically, Mau is a very, very good editor. >> But he
shows the entire report without the black bar sensors. So Cameron
is both lying about where he got this report and who censored
it. Now that we've established the dishonesty, let's actually
examine the document. I've gone through and edited red bar to
any sensitive information. The black bar on the top is likely
related to Cameron's gun safe and the bar on the bottom is likely
medical information relating to the Baker Act. And let's talk
about the supposed Baker Act. It's not about Krex. While I'll
keep the individual's name censored, you can see he is labeled
as a black male born in 1987.
>> Wait, wait. >> I'm not sure if this is Cameron's
roommate or another tenant of the apartment complex or someone
completely unrelated, but it's not about KXA. And Cameron knows
this. He censors the race, gender, and date of birth, which makes
it impossible for viewers to know this isn't about >> That's
insane. >> Cracka unless they see the uncensored version,
which at this point would be next to impossible. to summarize.
>> Okay. No way. That's insane.
That's >> Lied about what the report says. He lied about
how he got it and he lied about who redacted it. And he did this
all to make someone accusing him of abuse look mentally unstable.
To be clear, I don't fault Cameron for censoring the report himself
as a baseline to protect your >> Oh, no. But he didn't
he didn't censor He censored it to hide to just lie. However,
maliciously censoring a police report to smear someone accusing
you of abuse. That's like fabricating an entire report is very
different than simply protecting your privacy. This is extremely
egregious and malicious behavior. And I >> Wait, hold on.
How did FPS Diesel even foyer this? How did FPS Diesel even foyer
this document if it's not related to Cameron or or the Krexa
person
that >> don't know how he got away with this for so long?
Cameron also paredited these claims to other content creators
like FPS Diesel who ended up including this in their own video.
Now, Krexler herself has a pretty checkered history with former
men, homelessness,
>> wait FPS Diesel had the unredacted copy of this and
didn't look at the >> mental illness and a lot more that
called the girl unstable and into question. Right. The police
report my team and I got detailed the previous Baker Act. This
report is real. I am the reason the report leaked. Cameron likes
to act tough in these videos, proudly lying about his detractors
and victims. He will openly attempt to paint his critics as while
privately apologizing and begging for Reddit avowels. It goes
without saying that Diesel should have looked at the police report
himself and just trusting Cameron at his word was a bad move.
This allowed Crex to be smeared. Yeah. Uh hold on. Obviously,
did he not did he not talk about this? He's mentioning it. He
has the police report. He didn't think to glance at it. >> by
a large majority of the community. And to this day, lies about
Crexa have not been corrected on any large
2023 was definitely not a very good year for Cameron as only
three months I I would want to see the rest of that report. I'm
not sure. I feel like there's no way that report Hold on. I'm
going to I'm going to copy my my time stamp here. Copy my time
stamp. Take a second cuz
give me a second. I need to I need to go and check this again
when they're showing the report.
So text comple versus friend blank
black shorts known to have pocket knife white male. What is
m
accomplice
compl I don't even I don't know how to read this first part white
male white shirt gray shorts sig zero blank secured and safe
oh weapon gun pri one location has shown violent tendencies via
social media toward a select group of people uh people Baker
acted here
use extreme cautions uh multiple units should respond requests
her to be 20B but can't tell exactly what she's What is the ordering
here? It's bottom. It's bottom to top. So like this is about
her, right? And this Okay. So what's happening is they might
have been acting asking for a baker act here for for Crexa.
But it looks like the the former the the previous Baker act thing
that's hidden here and used against her is not against her. It's
one of the other people there. Hazard. So there's a hazard for
this. Oh, my roommate's been bakered before. Okay, I see. I see
how this is going. No, no, no. This is the same night. It's probably
they're going to respond to something about her, but they're
saying on scene there would be somebody like we probably got
warned that there is somebody like this who has violent tendencies
or >> has a well established history of dishonesty and
>> complain it. Complain it
>> complainant versus friend this person.
Okay, so let's actually don't
on the bottom is likely.
>> So
has shown violent tendencies. Use extreme caution. Multiple units
should respond. So this will be about her later on scene. Okay.
323A
>> There should be more pages for this as well. There should
be like more pages based on what actually happened here, right?
original call verbal disposition
>> to the Baker Act and whatever. >> After was kicked
out of his apartment, he now has to deal with the fallout of
Yandere Dev, his boss, being exposed as a child groomer. This
was first outed on the 20th of September when a Tik Tocker going
by Bugell leaked the contents of an upcoming expose video that
would be posted 4 days later. Cameron is seen in the comments
claiming this alleged minor Dev had interacted with had lied
about her age and was actively urging others to mass report the
videos exposing Dev. Cameron claims in recent Google documents
that he was lied to about Yandere
Dev about the minor's age, but the screenshots he links to site
this don't help his case. By the way, I maintain I I don't remember
the drama well, okay, but I think the Yandere Dev was actually
that that guy was actually groomed by the miners. Those miners
had significant significantly more social and mental maturity
than the Yandere Dev guy. Okay.
Very rare case of this guy being so brutally as like a 30-year-old
man or 35-year-old man that he was groomed by high schoolers.
Okay. They like took these videos, they took all this of him
like talking with this girl and they shared it in their own group
chats and just laughed at this guy. It wasn't a real relationship.
They were catfishing this guy and mocking the out of him. I'm
not even joking. Like we could go through it. That was my read
on the whole thing. I thought he he basically was like too function.
>> In fact, they contradict him. Yander. >> Yes.
Miners was basically my read when I remember hearing about it,
but I think it was before I ever streamed. >> Says, "Do
high school girls notice how much money they could make on Only
Fans and plan to start in Only Fans when they turn 18? What about
you? Are you going to do it?" This reads to me as, "Will you
start in Only Fans when you turn 18?" Basically admitting to
Cameron that he was indeed talking to an underage individual.
Despite this, he was on TikTok asking for the mass reporting
of this information. information that would have supposedly proven
Yandere Dev's guilt. And the video posted just 4 days later confirmed
everything. It exposed Yandere Dev engaging in deeply inappropriate
conversations with someone known as Jelly, who at this time was
only 16. Considering Yandere Dev was well into his 30s, this
was for all intents and purposes a closed case. Which begs the
question, why was Cameron willing to lie to defend someone whom
he had complete and in you shouldn't lie to defend him. You can
just defend him on like the the people who were like talking
to this guy were using it to like mock him in group chats. >> Some
cases exclusive knowledge of his wrongdoings. Cameron's odd choices
get even more bizarre as we go further into the timeline as Cameron
would plan to and successfully meet up in real life with Yandere
Dev's grooming victim four separate times. >> What? So
he goes and hangs out with the jelly person too. Bruh
bro. What? >> But before we go any further things are about
to get significantly more serious. I want to make something perfectly
clear. Cameron was 19 and Jill was 16. That's a three-year age
gap. And at no point in this video are the allegations about
the age gap being inherently predatory.
Dude, there's no way. He was like, "Oh, my boss just got cancelled."
Dude, what's the timeline? Cuz Ralph was seeming to lay it out
like after the boss gets cancelled for being the 16-year-old,
Cameron's like, "Oh,
free miner for me, boys. Let's go. There's no way. There's no
way that this guy is still on the internet hanging out and doing
there's >> or even inappropriate on its own. Cameron has
tried to turn this into a situation about a poor age gap and
being slandered as a and some content creators have even gone
along with this narrative as well. So, let me be perfectly clear.
Cameron is being accused of a long string of manipulative, coercive,
and outright malicious actions against someone he met under extremely
quy by the way. I wouldn't even have a problem with the 1916
dynamic most of the time. I'm not I don't even feel the need
to call that, right? But I think it's insane to know that this
person had a relationship with a 30-year-old inappropriately
got that guy like called a right like like reported that guy.
I again I can't not see the malice in the 16-year-old. I'm sorry.
Based on those those like audio recordings, I'd have to go I'd
have to go back and listen to like the interviews and stuff.
I remember they even got backlash. It was so blatant that I think
broadly the internet was like, "Oh, these 16-year-old these 16-year-old
grooming victims ain't no angels." Okay, which is just a wild
outcome in any case. All right, but then to take that girl and
to go meet up with her, I don't know. I don't know what the going
on. >> Questionable circumstances and none of these actions
hinge on the age gap. >> 19 and 16 is it's not
I'm sorry. Those two people could have met as a freshman in high
school and a senior in high school. That's how that relationship
could have started. Now, that's about as wide as we let that
that age gap go, right?
But they did not, did they? No, they didn't. But they could have.
It's an age gap that we allow. They could have met up in a social
space, right? Which they did, idiot.
The whole reason you allow it with the 19-year-old in high school
is cuz they share a social space. These two share a social space
right now. Yeah. It's like it's on the border. And what makes
it weird is that he's like, "Oh, you wait. You're kind of like
a victim of this guy. You're like kind of a victim of my boss.
Well, I want to go. Wouldn't you want to meet up in real life?
>> It's not the age gap that's the issue. It is the behavior.
So, if you're stuck on the number 16,
>> go for the sake of this video and the arguments that
follow. The age gap is mostly irrelevant. As >> although
I would say other people would just call him a Ralph's not going
to >> mentioned earlier, Cameron and Jelly met in person
a total of four times originally to meet on a documentary about
Yandere Dev. According to Jelly, these meetings took place on
Tuesday, November 21st, Saturday, November 25th, sometime during
Christmas break with no specific date given, and finally on Tuesday,
January 2nd. Cameron at this time lived in Florida and Jelly
in Pennsylvania. So, their meetings aligned with school holidays,
Thanksgiving, Christmas, and New Year's during which Cameron
was visiting family up north. The latter two times are really
the focus here, as those are the two times when alleged misconduct
took place on Cameron's part. to start. During their third meeting
over Christmas break, Jelly claims that Cameron attempted to
forcefully perform oral on her. She stated, quote, "He tried
to eat me out and I didn't want to, so I had to start hitting
him and stuff, so he would put me down." She also reiterates
the same exact
thing in a recent interview.
>> No, I'm not interested. And he was like, "You know,
I really like eating girls out." And I was like, "Okay, I'm not
interested."
And I gave him a whole bunch of reasons why. Um, just like >> Did
dickers really have to wear the knitted sweater for this? Don't
you have like a button-up or something? Do you have to wear the
Mr. Rogers knitted sweater for this one? Dickers, really? >> Mostly,
I'm not into that, especially not with someone who looks like
him. So, I just repeatedly was telling him like, "No, I'm not
really into that." >> And he was like, "No, you'll be fine."
And I was like, "No, leave me alone. No, I'm not doing that."
And he picked me up like physically lifted me and tried to move
my pants and put me down on his face and I was kicking him because
like what the
you can't just do that. >> Cameron, however, tells a very
different >> uh you can't just do that. Well, it turns
out he can. He just shouldn't. Okay, sounds like he did. He just
>> Different version of events. >> In this instance,
she was
feeling bad and she's like, "You didn't assault me." Whatever.
D. And then we were talking about the situation and I was like
I picked you up >> and it's not explain I put you down.
>> But explain the picking up. Explain the picking up.
How did Where were you? Just like tell tell a story here. >> So
we were we were in a parking lot >> and you know we were
coming out of a store. I picked her up cuz like I hugged her
and I picked her up while hugging her and she kind of like stopped
like you know she was kind of like non-verbal. She wasn't really
She started like I guess like moving around and uh >> this
is this cannot be your defense.
This cannot be your defense. It cannot be your defense.
She was nonverbal.
>> Hugging her and she kind of like stopped like you know
she was kind of like non-verbal. She wasn't really She started
like I guess like moving around.
>> And uh I could at that point I kind of realized that
she was uncomfortable and she was like stop. So, I put her down
and uh I was like, "Are you okay? What's wrong?" And she's like,
"Explained to me that she had past trauma with being picked up."
And I was like, "I'm so sorry. I didn't know that." And she said, "It's
okay, Cam. You didn't know." >> The story Cameron is now
pushing about this taking place in a parking lot appears, from
what I can tell, for the first time ever here. He never mentions
the parking lot in his r/ Osana video, nor in any of his prior
responses. Meanwhile, Jell's account has remained consistent
for over a year and a half, backed by this screenshot, as well
as activity in FPS Diesel's live chat from over a year ago. In
that chat, she mentions Cameron couldn't have seen her crotch
due to their positioning. And while I was streaming, Jill even
provided me with this.
the candid sketch of the non-consensual
>> this image to describe what happened. >> dude,
dude, the eyeballs. Why? Oh yes, it might look silly, but it
illustrates something important. According to her, Cameron was
laying down. She was sitting upright, and he grabbed her thighs
in an attempt to pull her onto his face. It's obviously a weird
and uncomfortable story, but what matters here is consistency.
Jelly has stuck to this version of events for well over a year.
Meanwhile, Cameron's explanation is completely new, never mentioned
before, and conveniently absolves him of any wrongdoing. Even
in leaked DMs with Yandere Dev, Jelly is seen describing the
same exact thing. FPS Diesel in his video covering Cameron also
included an audio clip that seems to reference this exact encounter.
>> You He said that you did nothing wrong.
>> Well, in the in a legal standpoint. >> From a
legal standpoint,
I was saying no and I was scared and that I didn't want to.
No, just in the sense of us having
and that can be argued because I once I heard you say stop, I
put you down. You were being nonverbal.
>> I don't think I was.
>> I I'm telling you maybe I wasn't hearing correctly,
but I'm tell >> you were being non-verbal, but maybe I
wasn't hearing correctly. By the way, when I first heard this
audio clip, this is not the first time I'm hearing this audio
clip, but when I first heard this audio clip, I thought this
was all like a bit because I'm like, there's no way this guy
like would actually say these things. There's no way you would
go on like some Discord call and say these things honestly like
say these things, dude. Let me just back it up on verbal. >> I
don't think I was
>> I I'm telling you maybe I wasn't hearing correctly,
but I'm telling you that I did not hear the word stop until I
did. I put you down and I felt awful because you said you were
like once you like started like squirming a bit. I felt >> squirming.
You're going to call it squirming. I was hitting you. >> Were
you? >> What the [__]
Oh my god. >> I like that he he doesn't say like no that
didn't happen. Were you? Were you? You were like squirming. She's
like I'm hitting I was hitting you and squirming no. And he's
like you seem non-verbal and like you were slightly squirming.
>> I'm sorry. I just >> By the way, that's like not
funny. That's actually not funny. But I'm He's just The way he's
like responding in this video is crazy. >> Oh my god. >> I'm
sorry. I just I didn't Well, obviously I wasn't intending to
do something bad to you. >> Cameron ended up responding
to >> sure sounds like something bad happened. >> Audio
clip in a private call with FPS Diesel in which he repeats the
nature of this encounter.
>> Forcibly lifted her up and wouldn't stop and that Anne
was hitting you.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
That wasn't encounter.
>> That wasn't a encounter.
>> because it is described as a encounter. >> I know.
I remember how it was phrased. I remember how it was. >> So,
what happened?
>> That was I already explained this like billion times
before. >> Dude, one HP voice for real though. I I already
explained this before like
many times. But like that was when we had like met >> uh
I think it was like the second or third fourth time we met. I
can't
>> It was the second time that day that we rem up.
>> Uh I hugged her. I picked her up. >> Like that
was kind of like a like a big old hug. You know what I mean?
Like I was picking her up. She freaked out. I didn't know she
didn't like that. And like that was something she was
not
>> That can't possibly be. So, I think Ral's drawing was
on a bed, right? This is on a bed. That's not That can't possibly
be what he's describing here, is there? Can it be? It can't be.
He's like describing meeting up outside for the first time, like
picking her up in a bear hug. >> She started like flailing
around, I >> Cameron also claims he was being blackmailed
into saying he had with >> What do you think I'm calling
you about,
>> dog? I don't know, man. Cuz what? You're You're a free
man from Yandre Dev. That's all like a year ago now. Yeah, I
have been for a while. Also, I I I should probably be very clear
about this. I wanted to tell you this a while back and I think
now I can finally explain this. I did not have Jelly. Um, the
reason I said that, the reason I was pressured into saying that
was because she had blackmail over me over something that happened
to me when I was younger. It doesn't matter. >> I don't
care anymore because I have proof of her blackmailing me now.
>> This is a lie. Cameron later admits they did indeed
have and that the blackmail was to apparently delete exonerating
evidence. Not to say him and Jill had >> Okay, so there
were aspects of my interviews with Diesel where I wasn't honest
with him. Whether it be out of embarrassment, I couldn't trust
him.
>> Dude, this guy is uh this is some Tom Foolery tier like
just
just lying. Just just compulsively lying, right? like you have
no there's no go he like things that could easily be disproven
if anybody checks with anyone else it'll immediately be dispelled
and you're just compulsively lying about everything >> or
you know all of that but and of course you know the blackmail
uh like I'm very uncomfortable with this person at this point
I'm not trying to like get >> why are you giving stone
like and like like giving it to >> let's go back to point
one the blackmail and during this time she had asked me to share
my screen and so I had to stop the recording. She saw the recording.
She asked me to delete everything and I didn't make a backup
because you know I wasn't thinking about that at that moment
in time. It had just it had just occurred dude like it had just
occurred.
>> Wait, why? I don't know why you would delete evidence
like exonerating >> because I was in a she forced me to
like there was nothing I could do at that point. In my mind I
was being forced to do it. Cameron to this day has not provided
any evidence of any blackmail and has been avoidant when >> bro
no wonder he hates Aiden though he goes on Aiden's stream and
incriminates >> never pressed about it but let's move past
this if Cameron wasn't being blackmailed about what's with this
whole picking up incident in FPS Diesel's video Cameron seemingly
doesn't deny the oral occurred according to Diesel he replied
to the statement saying that it wasn't basically arguing the
consent aspect of this encounter
wow at camera 305 great look she said this right here This was
before I knew about Alex. The full truth. That ain't news. Sims
4 DLC to say we didn't meet up or that he didn't do anything
bad to me. He did do some of the things, but he apologized and
made up for it. So, I've forgiven him.
Wait, there's no way. She said, "I'll I'll say you didn't me
if you buy me Sims 4 DLC. Please tell me that's not what's being
communicated here, cuz I'm pretty sure that's what's being communicated
here." And I don't know.
I don't know what I don't know how to handle it. I don't know
how to handle it. Okay, that seems to be what's being communicated
here. Is this This seems to be from a Discord group chat. It's
at minimum Discord group chat or Discord channel they're all
in. He did do Sims 4 DLC to say we didn't meet up or that he
didn't do anything bad to me. >> Rather than if the encounter
ever happened at all. So, if the eating out incident is completely
and utterly false, as Cameron claims, why even offer an alternative
explanation if nothing happened? The only way Cameron's version
makes any sense is if we believe that Jelly invented her story
from thin air and then an oddly similar sanitized version of
events had already taken place that conveniently removes any
wrongdoing from his part. That means one of two things is true.
Either Cameron is lying to cover up a deeply uncomfortable incident
and slowly rewriting the past every time he speaks about it,
or we're supposed to believe that the following happened. A similar
event had already taken place that by sheer chance mirrors the
core physical setup of Jelly's story, but just so happens to
make Cameron look innocent. He conveniently forgot to tell this
story in multiple other public explanations over the span of
a year. And he lied about what he was being blackmailed about,
now claiming he was being blackmailed to delete fully exonerating
evidence that would supposedly completely prove him innocent.
Either Cameron is lying or the universe orchestrated the most
bizarre chain of contradictory events just to make him look guilty.
Obviously, >> sounds like you just bought the DLC. We're
never going to know the full story here, but given Cameron's
history of dishonesty as well as the insane absurdity that would
need to have taken place here for He's talking someone who doesn't
know about this story. How do you think this video is? Um, it's
interesting. It's good. I think your music levels are slightly
too loud in like the early part. I thought the in the intro I
didn't like the the levels. >> is Chain of Events to be
true? I'm not exactly confident Cameron, >> but yeah, I
can't pick apart like factual issues here. I think it's being
presented well. I think it meandered a little bit around I think
there was one part I thought it meandered a little bit but honestly
>> suddenly being honest here the fourth and final time
Cameron and Jelly met is arguably the most clear-cut when it
comes to his wrongdoings as Cameron himself practically admits
to it. But first let's go over Jelly's account as shared in a
recent interview. >> We went to another church parking.
>> It will just be your pay. >> Oh hello >> Ben
Ruben donated $3. She wasn't nonverbal. She was probably speaking
>> I assume that's the language in the Sims. Thank you.
>> Took me to Duncan because he was trying to warm me up
to him and he knows that I like Dunkin Donuts. So, he took me
there and he was trying to get me to warm up to him again and
he was being weird the >> I have to listen I have to listen
to that again. >> He went to another church parking lot.
He took me to Duncan because he was trying to warm me up to him
and he knows that I like Dunkin Donuts. So he took me there and
he was trying to get me to warm up to him again and he was being
weird the whole time. He was like, "It's not that big of a deal.
I didn't mean >> I know. I know I violated your consent,
but everybody loves Duncan. >> Really? My fault. And you
were nonverbal. You're bad at communicating. And it was just
like a whole thing. And I all day was being like, "Whatever.
You're a jerk. Leave me alone." So, >> this girl is wifey
material. Satisfied by DLC and Duncan, someone marry her. I don't
know about that. Soapbox. I don't know about that. The And if
she's like the primary thing in the uh in the Yandere Dev
drama, I don't I wouldn't trust this person.
>> He tried. Yeah. He we were like 40 minutes away from
my house and I wanted to go home because I was just so dumb with
him and he would not take me home like all day and I wasn't panicking
until it was night time. I was like, "Oh my god, he's going to
kill me." Which I doubt he would, but you know, I was panicking
because he wouldn't let me out of his car. >> And then
he was like, "Well, >> so to be clear on that, um just
you say that he didn't let you out of his car. Um did you ask
to be let out?" Yeah, multiple times. I've been telling him all
day, "Take me home. Let me out." And he wouldn't. >> But
oh, you got to press on that. Like, why couldn't you get out
of the car in one of the locations you stopped at? You say you
went to Dunkin Donuts. Were you incapable of leaving the car
or were you saying that like you asked to leave and then you
decided to stay after after you guys like warmed up again? Like,
>> okay. Um, >> you got to press harder on that one.
That that can't be allowed just like that, right? You need that
information. If they if they were like stopping at random places,
you had every opportunity to get out of the car and she's saying,
"Well, he wouldn't let me out of the car because he wouldn't
pull over at some point while you were having a fight." Those
aren't the same thing, right? Being like, if you're making the
actual like allegation that he was like kidnapping you or wouldn't
let you out, it can't just be that you wouldn't he wouldn't pull
over at some random point. It has to be that you for long periods
of time were prevented from leaving his
>> right? I don't think >> and at some point he's
>> I came up with like a curfew thing. I was like, "My
dad's texting me and he really wants me home. I need to go home
now." Which is not true. My dad did not care where I was as long
as I let him know I would not be home that night. >> So,
that was >> Okay. So, at some point, >> I was coming
up with every excuse in the book to go home. He would not let
me go home. And then he was like, "Just kiss me before you go."
And I was like, >> "Oh my god, I don't want that. Can you
just take me home?" And he was like, "No, I'm not letting you
out until you kiss me." And I was like, "What the? That's immature."
And he was like, "Well, I just really want to spend time with
you. I feel >> No, no, JTock. Just not letting them out
is considered kidnapping." I don't think it's kidnapping to be
driving along the side of the road with somebody you're dating
on a date with or and that you've known for a while, right? I
I think this is the third or fourth time they met or something,
but that you're like in some kind of relationship with. And when
they say, "Pull over right now and let me out." And you're like,
"No, I don't think that's kidnapping. I'm sorry." You could say
that's like technically kidnapping. I think that's I think that's
completely it's absolutely kidnapping. Uh if you're like driving
around for a long period of time, if you're just like, "Okay,
I'm going to like go and drive to some other like we're we're
going over here. You can get out there and and like get out of
the car, right? That's that's what I would say. If you're on
Reddit, it's kidnapping." I think these people just have never
been in like relationships and gotten in a fight with somebody
who's like, "Let me out of this car right now." It's like, "Okay,
well, we're like 10 minutes away from where we're going. We'll
stop there and then you can we can split up there."
That that seems totally fine to me. >> Like we have such
a connection and I >> Yes. If you're if you're like if
you're like not if you're basically her only way to drive or
something and cuz she's 16 so you're her only way to drive. Her
phone's dead. You know she needs you to get home. That would
be like Yeah, there could be circumstances where this would >> Feel
bad. I don't want to burn any more bridges. And he went on this
thing about how all of his friends leave him and Alex betrayed
him. >> Hold on. Uh, I saw a case where a boyfriend picked
up their ex and was driving down the road and he didn't let her
out when she said, "Let me out and he got felony kidnapping.
He spent a year in prison before the lawyer got his case appealed."
That's insane. That's >> Him and just I don't know like
a sympathy thing tried to get me to kiss him and I was like,
"Oh my god, no." And then he grabbed me by my shoulder and he
pulled me over onto him and he kissed me and then he finally
drove me home and I was looking out the other direction trying
not to cry. by the entire ride, but he wasn't actually taking
me home. He was taking me close to my grandma's house so that
I could come into my grandma's house. >> According to Jelly,
Cameron, >> took her to Duncan and then parked in a lot.
She says she repeatedly asked him to take her home, a 40-minute
drive from the parking lot. She says she made up a curfew to
try to pressure him. Despite this, Cameron, >> okay,
this makes it feel significantly worse to me. 40 minutes away
from home. I miss that detail. If it's 40 minutes away from her
home, that's like a really expensive Uber, right? If and like
it shouldn't be an emergency situation. If she's saying, "I want
to go home now. I want to go home now." You should be taking
her home. You should be like, if she's like, "I'm uncomfortable.
I want to go home. You should be taking her home." Or cuz she
said like, "Let me she wants to get out or something." Yeah,
you should be going around to to take her home. >> Allegedly
refused to drive her back until she kissed him. Jelly claims
that after enough back and forth of her refusing, Cameron eventually
grabbed her and kissed her anyway and then finally took her home
to her grandmother's house. This isn't just her word either.
This incident is largely corroborated in a recording Jelly secretly
took where even the part about Cameron grabbing her is being
discussed.
>> What about
how I >> depends on how close the relationship is, soap
box? I go back and forth. I'm like, well, if you're in a relationship
with somebody that seems like absurd like obviously they could
escalate to a point where I'd be like, oh, I will let you out,
right? But if they're just like, "Let me out. I want to get out."
And be like, "No, come on." And then obviously once they're agit
if they if they like if they if it was like, "Oh, they're going
to become agitated be like, "Okay, I will let you out." But like
I think, man, there's a lot of social dynamics. I guess you need
to know the other person pretty well, right? Like people can
say like that. Like I want to get out of the car right now, right?
It's just Yeah, there's a lot of other things going on. minutes
telling you that I didn't want to kiss you and then you wouldn't
let me go. >> Haven't we already been over this? Like,
you know, I I feel horrible about that. And it was only because
I wanted to spend more time with you. I wasn't trying to force
you to do something. >> But you can't just act like you
didn't do anything wrong. >> I'm I That's the first thing
I said to you. Like I
like you said, I didn't do anything wrong in the sense of like
anything illegal. And I, you know, in in regards to the idea
of us having and that's all I was talking about, not that between
that's why I said obviously between us, I know I made mistakes
and I feel horrible for them because I broke a boundary that
I didn't realize I was breaking and and I feel awful. >> You
didn't realize you were breaking it. Me telling you that I didn't
want to and that I was scared and not to grab me. >> How
does Cameron explain the situation? Well, on multiple occasions,
he downplays what happens, saying how it's not a big deal or
that it's over. >> Dude, he um
Okay, so this guy is like, you don't find the Tom Fooleries this
early most of the time where they just pathologically lie like
constantly
>> And by the way, um the whole kissing thing was
uh it definitely like was a weird situation, but uh what really
like happened there was uh it w like I wasn't forcing her to
kiss me. Okay, I want to make that very clear. Okay. >> Um,
I asked for one. She gave it to me cuz she thought that was her
way to like go home cuz she was afraid of curfew. That's what
was happening. >> And I just wanted to spend a little bit
more time with her cuz we had like 30 minutes and like we were
like 10 minutes away. I was like, we can spend a couple like
we could spend like 15 more minutes, but she was like anxious
about curfew. That's what was happening. >> And yeah, I
guess like in hindsight, yeah, I was being pushy and I apologized
for it. This is like again a year and a half old. >> Oh,
the the kiss. uh you just yeah we'll watch that interview also
>> she tried to and the way she had framed it in this call
and I even remember like thinking at the time like that's weird
but she had like tried to change the aspect of the situation
where what actually happened was she had a curfew in like 30
minutes and we were like 5 10 minutes away from her home and
I just wanted to spend more time cuz we were having a good day
and you know that we were like hugging we were hanging out whatever
I asked for a kiss uh she gave me the kiss and apparently later
on she had told me that she was scared. She wanted to go home.
She was afraid of missing curfew. And that was like a whole thing.
And I just wanted to spend more time with her. And I was being
a little pushy, I'll admit. Not to get a kiss, but to spend more
time with her. >> Notably, in that second interview, Cameron
claims they were only 5 or 10 minutes away from Jell's house.
This is false. According to Jelly's Google Maps data, the location
of where they were parked was actually about 30 minutes from
her home. This data also shows the stop at Dunkin Donuts and
the Oh,
no.
the the
the unbeatable receipts. Oh no. >> Church parking lot perfectly
lining up with her version of events. Her grandmother's house,
the place where she was ultimately dropped off at, is also 30
minutes away. On foot, that's a 2-hour walk. And to her parents
house would have been over 5 hours of walking. So what kind of
position did Cameron put her in? >> You know, they can't
refuse because of the implication. >> Cameron wouldn't
take her home unless she kissed him. The implication being that
if she refused, she'd have to walk. It doesn't matter that he
didn't say the words out loud. The implicit threat of isolation
and having to walk home at dark as a 16-year-old is very clear.
Cameron's bizarre lies. This is pretty bad. I don't know if he
could have loaded all of that like connotation in. I don't know
how aware he was, but dude, the lying and stuff like if you come
hat in hand and say, "Hey, I really didn't think about this.
I see how bad it looks in retrospect and I reallyed up." You
say that. Okay, that's all right. Right. Like, sorry, that's
not all right. But at least you're at least you're telling the
truth and throwing your mercy at throwing yourself at the mercy
of other people. It's maybe not all right. Maybe that's not the
quite the right word, but like I could see that the constant
lying and calling everybody else a liar, that's where you up,
right? You I could let this guy go on like, "Oh, you're 19, you're
like, you didn't get it and this was bad, but like you don't
have to be cancelled for it, right?" Like, if I did that with
somebody,
I should be I I should probably be in trouble, right? Like that's
pretty bad. But like somebody who really doesn't have that much
experience, I'm like, "Okay, you really you this up. It's bad.
Everything's saying here is true. I'm just saying I could have
let it go without the lying." But all of the lying lying about
this to make other people look bad is like terrible in this is
don't stop there. At one point he tries to tell Diesel that he
was never even interested in Jelly. >> I didn't have her.
I wasn't interested in her. I met her to interview her. >> That
immediately falls apart. Why would Cameron pressure someone he
wasn't interested in to kiss him? Why would he go out of his
way to meet her four separate times? Why would he flash his erect
member in a call with Jelly as
See, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. But this Jelly person, this is this
is crazy. Okay, this person, the reason Cameron knows this person
is because as far as I can remember, and if this is the right
person from the Yandere Dev allegations, they were recording
stuff with Yandere Dev and they were like always sending to group
chats making fun of the guy, right?
That's that's who this person was. That's how you met them. Okay?
You don't show your on camera to this person. Okay? You don't
do that. You don't do that. You don't do that. You don't do it.
What are you doing, man? What are you doing? Oh, boy. >> Some
sort of joke. Most importantly, why would Cameron spend over
130 US? >> Oh, no. The DLC >> Steve on Steam gifts
over the course of 3 months following the car kissing incident.
No, I'm not. >> Dude, no way. >> Joking. 12 Steam
>> Horse Ranch Expansion. Dude, is this girl Does this
girl have just a racket going? She like gets she gets like
to engage with her. They they up as they're always going to.
And then she's like, "Now buy me Steam games." >> Gifts
that all add up to $13368
after applying Steam sales. Check the email. I'm sorry. This
is the least I can do. Best wishes, Cam. I love you. >> Oh
no, >> you two. Xoxo.
Contacting you without being contacted first is something I'm
working on stopping. It bothers you and I want you to be happy.
as a punishment. Have a
>> bro. Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. You're
so Oh, this is soed up. This is soed up. This is how how how.
Hope all is well. Can't wait to start fresh. Here's the DLC's,
I promise. I don't want anything in return, Spur. Jelly stated
that at one point these gifts were to buy her silence. And looking
at some of the messages, that's definitely implied. But with
others, there's clearly a deeper emotional context here. If this
was just about keeping her quiet, Cameron sure had a funny way
of doing it. Cameron has been alleged of scripting calls with
Jelly, essentially making Jelly say incriminating things on recorded
calls, which Cameron then misuses for his benefit. The most important,
and in my opinion, the most plausible is to do with Jell's alleged
honeypotss. In FPS Diesel's original Yand >> dude Cameron
is one of her honeypots video mentions labeled as smoking gun.
>> But essentially I had been asking for proof that this
girl ran a honeypotss and she would coach her friends on how
to do it as well. Cameron would go on to make good on this and
he sent me an MP3 file titled smoking gun.mpp3.
I will now play this clip for you in
>> I'm sorry. Like you can make this point and I agree.
This person seems like she is trying to honeypot people. Okay,
that's what it seems like. Without hearing this clip, I'll just
say right off the bat, it seems like she's trying to honeypot
people, but I don't even care about that. Cameron's the one who's
lying about all of the right. He's the one who's making all of
these incredibly inconsistent statements. Like, he obviously
did, too. Like, it doesn't matter, bro. If somebody's honeypotting
you for some reason. If somebody's like wants to you, they have
an alternative motive. An ulterior motive rather. You don't get
to them. That's not how it go. You You wanted to blackmail me
for money if we Well, now you're getting that doesn't work. That's
not a get out of jail free card. That is not a thing. Okay. You
can't do that. >> Really? Well, so then I made the honeypot
rules with the most frequently asked questions. >> So,
you didn't run one, but you >> I didn't run it. >> You
coached people on how to run one. >> Yeah. other underage
girls.
>> Just my bones. >> And how did >> like, "Hey,
I'm
guy. He plays a lot of World of Warcraft." And I was like, "Oh,
>> So, it was more of like a a hair. >> Oh, that's
that guy sounds like I bet you can. I I bet you can get him with
some concents
>> kind of. What Jelly is admitting to here is essentially
grooming other kind of >> miners into honeypotting, which
if true would be incredibly dangerous. However, this seems to
be mostly a lie perpetrated by Cameron as 4 days after FPS Diesel's
video was posted, Cameron apologizes for the smoking gun clip
and says he tried to get Diesel to remove >> I feel like
I feel awful about the whole smoking gun
>> That made me so mad at you. >> Oh, why is he still
talking to her after doing this? There's no way, dude. I'm sorry.
That's one of those moments, okay? That's what they call a bridge
burning moment. All right? You never talk to that person on a
digital device ever again. Okay? You never ever ever talk to
this person again. You go and you say, "This person runs honeypotss.
They try to as a minor, they try to attract adults and then they
could blackmail them." Okay? And as an adult, I'm gonna hop back
in a Discord call with them.
Why? Why are either of them talking to each other? Um, I assume
I assume she wants to punish him in some way for the uh what
do you call it? Like this guy just made it sounds like he made
up about her. I'm guessing she wants proof of that. I'm guessing
that's how this audio clip exists, right? This doesn't sound
like it's on a stream. This sounds like them talking
>> about the the whole smoking gun clip. >> That
made me so mad at you. >> I know. I feel Listen, I deleted
it in uh early October. It was there for about three days and
I told him actually I don't think this is really what what went
down and he never let go of it and I'd always try to redirect
it. I told him not to include it cuz I didn't think it was a
proper representation. He knows >> it's not a proper representation.
>> So Cameron knew something was false and gave very little
push back to Diesel and allowed misinformation to spread effectively
smearing Jelly. I do want >> Well, he says he gave push
back to Diesel, but what a briefly bring up the honeypot rules
that Jelly made. >> Oh god, no.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Don't dox him if you DM him first. He isn't in a place to resist.
Okay, Jelly's Honeypot rules. Don't dox him if you DM him first.
He isn't in a place to resist if you seduce him on purpose. If
you DM him first, within reason, you are not a victim.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. No leaking. Don't ruin the trust.
If you want to gather more evidence for an arrest, you need to
keep him feeling secure in your DMs. Don't expose him to anyone
other than the police. No romance promises. Okay. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. This is not blackmail. This is
not blackmail. Are you still fat? No. Any unique tips for weight
loss? No.
Uh, intermittent fasting was helpful the first time,
right? When I like initially lost a bunch of weight um when I
was like like I've talked about this on stream. When is it after
university? intering was good, but it's not like it's not actually
helpful. It just helps you organize like your meals in the day.
It's not really um it's not really like it doesn't make you like
less hungry. It's easier. I don't know. There were so many in
that Discord. She made some rules for it, dude. Um
this actually changes everything. This isn't to like blackmail
people. I thought it would be to blackmail people, but it seems
like it's like for trying to catch, which is still weird. No
romantic promises. Don't make any promises of marriage, love,
or baby. As soon as you start acting like a girlfriend, you are
not his groomie. Getting fetted by someone who loves him will
be traumatizing.
Okay.
Make sure he's sober one at a time. Dude, don't dox if he's loyal
to you. Dude, this is this is now this is weird. This is so much
weirder than I thought it would be. What the god. However, she
claims that these were satire in an interview. >> Um yeah,
also the honeypot thing. Um there there's a screenshot. It's
called the honeypot rules.
I was in >> detective jelly on >> a discord server
full of and every time they would say something weird to me I
would screenshot it and post it in gen chat and be like found
another one. So they were giving me all of their logic. So I
made
>> satire rules basically parodying
everything that I would commonly hear from them. >> This
being satire is pretty convenient. That being said, there's no
actual evidence of Jelly doing anything Honeypot related that
I've been able to find outside of these rules. So, it is very
plausible that they could indeed be satire. Jelly didn't really
Honeypot, or at least to the extent Cameron is pushing. And Cameron
fed Diesel misinformation to effectively smear Jelly. He's also
repeatedly lied about Jelly's age, both in private and in public.
In DMs to Diesel, he claimed the age gap between him and Jelly
was only a year and a half. >> But like, I was also like,
"Oh, it's like a year." Dude, every every single thing he says
is alive. >> It's so brutal.
>> I don't care. Um, >> it was it was 1916.
>> And on one of Diesel's live streams, he tried to pass
off Jelly as 17 when all of this happened when she was in fact
>> The argument is, you're 19,
she's 16.
For some people, they say that's just I know she's 17 now. Wouldn't
you have sex with her? >> Why even lie about this? Most
likely he was trying to downplay the significance of the age
gap as during an interview with Jelly, he seemingly puts great
significance on her age, saying he won't call her Jelly Squish
because she's a >> Just call me Ann.
>> Okay. Well, they both start with a >> true damn
it. >> I'll call you Jelly Squish.
>> Squish also works.
>> That's I'm not calling any minor squish. Cameron clearly
knows what he did was wrong. But in his mind, the problem seems
to be that Jill was 16 and he was 19, which is not the issue
here. Cameron only knew this girl because his boss, Yandere Dev,
had groomed her. That's how they met. After knowing that, and
after seeing exclusive information about Dev's wrongdoings and
the things he was saying to this girl, he still chose to meet
up with her four times. He still
pressureed to kiss him under the >> I know. That's why
it's weird, dude. I again, man, I almost want to go recover the
Yandere Dev stuff now because of how up her conduct was. I swear
to God, it's the only time I've ever heard of like a minor getting
groomed where I'm like, "Oh, actually the minor the groomer and
like the the 30-year-old
developer is the victim here. Like, it's it's that bad. If I
remember correctly, it's like that bad." Implicit threat of abandonment
and according to Cameron even went so far as to have with her.
So, no. The issue with Cameron and Jelly isn't the age gap of
3 years between a 16-year-old and a 19-year-old. The issue isn't
even a 19-year-old and a 16-year-old having sex. The issue is
Cameron met an abuse victim through his employment under a predator
and after meeting up with her decided to implicitly threaten
her >> reverse grooming. Yes, but we're cutting off Marau's.
The issue isn't even a 19-year-old and a 16-year-old having The
issue is Cameron met an abuse victim through his employment under
a predator and after meeting up with her decided to implicitly
threaten her, attempt to smear her, and lie about the context
of their meetings and conversations. Everything wrong that happened
here happened in spite of the age gap, not because of it. More
recently, Cameron has attempted to go on a victory tour, for
lack of a better term, gloating in his content deputy that he
is innocent and that Noah Samson should be sued for what he had
said about Cameron, along with multiple tweets essentially bragging
that he had allegations with a 16-year-old and basically got
away with it, framing these allegations as lies or >> is
Brow worried about copyright infringement or
is this uh intellectual property theft? Bragging about a relationship
with >> Or exaggerated. And so after everything, what are
we laughing? A guy who built his career off of moral superiority,
who called on others for behavior he couldn't even begin to reflect
on himself. He has crossed boundaries, forged screenshots, edited
police documents, released intimate videos he refused to delete,
all to smear a girl accusing him of abuse. He met someone through
a situation involving predatory behavior from his own boss, and
then use that connection to manipulate her, lie about her, and
reframe the entire situation as a witch hunt over a three-year
age gap, just so he didn't have to be honest about the frankly
awful stuff he had done. In short, Cameron F305 is a liar, an
abuser, a manipulator, and should not be your go-to when it comes
to >> exposing creators like Idubbbz or Hassan. Cameron
can't even be honest about what he has done. In what world should
he be trusted to expose massive names or criticize bad behavior?
He isn't a content cop. He is a pathetic, lying fraud. I feel
obligated to say before I end off this video, I don't care about
Hassan or really even Idubbbz for that matter. >> This
is why he felt like a skinwalker in his content cop because he's
a skinwalker making up for his I mean, skinwalking is just like
uh I get the skinwalking thing, I guess. But it's just like
he's doing a Why can't we just call it an impression? It's like
or an homage
was do we forget the word the word homage? The word homage exists.
He's doing like an homage, right? He's trying to he's trying
to recreate it and he's a weirdo. I have [__] it.
>> My criticisms of Cameron should stand on their own outside
of any current political conflict or YouTube drama occurring.
I don't like Cameron and I think I've made a compelling case
against him. My issues are with Cameron and Cameron alone. Jelly,
Krexa, even FPS Diesel to some extent are able to and frankly
should be criticized for some of the things they have done. That's
not >> Dude, the FPS Diesel guy making it sound like Krex
was Baker acted when she may never have been. That would be really
weird, right? I That seems like a weird
like him just not reading the document at all. If that's if that
happened there, that would be a little crazy to me. NSE content
when
um I don't know if I'm gonna do NSE Techone tonight. >> Not
what this video is about though, and I feel like any conversation
past what Cameron himself has done is going to be a waste. Nothing
justifies what he had done to the women in his life, regardless
of what they did before or after they met him. Content Cop is
dead. What's left is a broken mimic trying desperately to grasp
on to what made the originals so special. And at the end of the
day, after all that I've shown you, do you really want this guy
as your bastion of YouTube critique? >> You guys win. The
pipsies, let's go.
Oh man. Would you wear this too for enough money? Um, I mean,
I would have to show my face and I'm not doing that uh in the
immediate future. So,
subscribe. Oh god. Oh my god. Guys, go and join me Nation.
Okay, we're subscribed. Go subscribe to me. The videos in the
com the video is pinned in the chat. Okay, like the video. Subscribe
to the channel. Subscribe to the channel. Get likes on the video.
Um, I would be interested because people are telling me Quean
didn't like the video. And I'm guessing that has to do with like
actually having a solid, you know, base of all the basis for
all the facts. But to me, it's like it's a good video explains
like some of the bad things he did. I wonder if this is the primary
criticism is that he will basically like do everything he can.
He will lie repeatedly. It's like he's a he's a pathological
liar
who
oh man, how would you describe it? Pathological liar who finds
people through like that community and discredits them in like
whatever way he can.
I don't know if I'd call him like a It kind of is predatory.
Yeah, I know. Quinn doesn't like anything. I get it. I know.
Bad clip selection was the main critique. really thought I missed
some